how strong is gyoko and his final
self-proclaimed Invincible form how far
do his demon water bending Powers go
after discussing upper moons six as well
as upper moons four through one it's
finally time to talk about number five
as he's center stage in the anime right
now so make sure to stay tuned for this
one chill the hot show with it and smash
that like button if you enjoy seeing
these Demon Slayer videos on the channel
and want to keep them coming join the
demon saying fam if you haven't by
subscribing and hitting that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications so you don't miss future
Demon Slayer videos and updates and now
without further Ado let's jump into It
spoilers and all gyoko debuts in chapter
98 and as I mentioned in my recent
huntengu video gyoku comes off much more
confident even if he's a lower ranked
upper Moon the lowest ranked present in
fact yet he's not intimidated by the
others as he pops out of his pot he
immediately starts talking to Lord akaza
as he calls him saying that he is glad
he is well he says and I quote it's been
about 90 years hasn't it I'd begun to
think you were defeated my chest was
tight from worry he he and quote gyoko
and upper Moon 2 Doma seemed to get
along pretty well as we find out Doma
got a pod from gyoko and used it to
decorate his room Doma even invites
gyoko to come visit sometime when muzon
comes and is chastising everyone gyoko
has the boldness to say he's different
he has information to bring busan's
hopes One Step Closer he's interrupted
by muzon taking his head off but since
it's not a nature and blade this doesn't
really mean any lasting damage or
anything still muzon could potentially
absorb Yoko and deal with him that way
however that's not what he's gonna do
gyoko is sweating thinking Lord muzon is
touching my head so very nice end quote
not what you'd expect his reaction to
decapitation to be and it makes sense
why he and Doma get along the two have a
similar evil and insane in a Joyful Way
Vibe going on mulsan straight up tells
Yoko that the first death of an upper
moon in 113 years this pleases him
immensely and tells gyoko to not ever
convey such unpleasant information so
gleefully again again though he didn't
really do anything significant to gyoko
and he moves on quickly telling gyoko
when the information is confirmed to go
there with upper moon for Han Tengu of
course it seems gyoko is the one with
the information about the swordsmith
village so despite being the lowest
upper Moon currently he proves very
useful and honestly if muzon was smart
enough to hit the swordsmith village
hard with all the demon moons or even
some stronger ones that information
could have delivered a way more
significant blow to the Demon Slayer
core but he underestimates The Village
defenses and only sends the two weakest
upper moons then later gyoko unaffected
by the decapitation gives nakime the
orders to send him and Han Tengu to the
same place clearly if you pay close
attention in contrast to hantangu who is
cowering in fear everywhere Kyoko has
some significant confidence and boldness
he takes pleasure in being decapitated
by muzon and these are always
interesting villains the ones who take
pleasure in the pain but let's see if
his confidence is well found it or if
it's just pure arrogance although it's
not mentioned in the manga we do know
gyoko's backstory from the fan books
which will put things into perspective a
bit before we get to his fight in his
feet his name was managi as a human and
he lived in a village at the edge of a
coastline it was a fishing Village so we
start to get hints of his eventual
obsession with fish his parents went out
on a fishing trip one day and never
returned they ended up drowning in the
sea and their mangled corpses washed up
in managi saw them this led to a
grotesque fascination with corpses at
first it wasn't as messed up as it got
he was obsessed with fish carcasses he
found but the villagers thought this was
weird and ostracized him believing he
had gone insane a kid eventually teased
him for his weird behavior and managi
killed the kid and stuffed him into a
fishing pot the child's parents
discovered what happened and stabbed
managi with a fishing spear a lot of
fish related stuff going on he was left
to die on the spot before muzon
discovered him and turned him into a
demon so it's very clear clear from the
backstory how he became the demon we
know today from his Fascination to fish
pots and corpses it's even noted that
gyoko developed a strong hatred for all
living things from his near-death
experience but worshiped his savior
moves on another nod to the backstory
we're told as a demon he primarily ate
the Flesh of children so the young 14
year old hasha muichiro definitely seems
like a fitting matchup for him we're
also told that he modified his demon
body to look like a fish how he did it I
don't know but that explains why he
looks so well fishy the rest we know he
developed the habit of abducting people
through his pots and he'd used them to
create his so-called Art of Living
statues for the artworks he'd often
leave his victims alive too despite
their mangled bodies the fact that he
hates all living things perhaps helps to
explain his complete lack of empathy for
his victims in time Joko would reach
upper rank 5 as we know and although his
intro doesn't make it look like it Yoko
is actually muson's favorite upper Moon
according to the fan book but primarily
because his ornate thoughts can sell for
a high price so now we have a bit of an
understanding of Guild code that even
people who read the entire manga would
not have now with this in mind let's
turn to his appearance on the
battlefield during chapter 107 we see a
surprise surprise growth task fish
corpse looking zombie chasing our little
swords with bro it's notable that gyoko
can summon these fish demons that could
themselves kill non-combatants at the
very least of course these fodder
Creations are sliced and diced easily by
a pro Prodigy like missed hashira
muichiro however since it's not the main
demon these fish demon regenerate when
their heads are cut and the pots have to
be destroyed Wichita realizes
immediately that they get their powers
from their attached pots and that it is
a blood demon art that created them
muichiro keeps taking down these fish
giant demons until he senses that Yoko
is in a nearby pot when upper Moon 5
Goku appears the first thing he wants to
do is show muichiro his three creations
of the night as he takes out the first
one from a pot he says it is called the
Death Rows of the Smiths we see mangled
combined swords with bodies in what
tagyoko is living suffering art he's so
messed up that he gets deep into art
analysis when it comes to his evil
Creations he says stuff like look at the
dirty hands with thick calluses like
swordsmiths get I put them in front on
purpose so gyoko is not just a strong
villain he's one of those Twisted ones
he even says running them through swords
brings out a certain smithiness and he
says he even left the masks on to convey
emotionlessness and absurdity and he
says if he twists the katana like this
it goes that is what I'm guessing that
scream is pronounced like and then we
hear the suffering of the still alive
swordsmith no joke gyoko sounds like a
first year university Dropout who now
applies what he learned to his Sick
Creations finally muichiro has had
enough and the actual battle between
hashira and upper Moon one-on-one begins
now gyoko is no joke he Dodges muichiro
initially teleporting from pot to pot to
one of his abilities so muichiro starts
aiming for and cutting the pots this
gets to Yoko saying how dare you destroy
my pots they are a work of art you
uncultured monkey starting to sound like
Frieza here the angered gyoko says a
muscle head like you couldn't possibly
appreciate my work which is also kind of
funny just because muichita is one of
the least muscular hashira muichiro is
very smart here deducing that if kyoko's
running away like this he will die if
muichiro cuts his head off unlike the
dividing demon so at least he knows
he'll be more straightforward to kill
now this is a drawback for gyoko but to
be fair the stronger upper moons also
don't rely on a tricky way to avoid
decapitation their vulnerability is
their neck but their overpoweredness
doesn't allow the demon Slayers to cut
it for the most part so at higher levels
we can't say vulnerability to
straightforward decapitation is a big
drawback Yoko then launches some weird
looking fish from a pot and they use the
thousand needle fish kill attack now
muichiro gets hit by these needles that
explode from the fish because he
protects the swordsmiths from them so in
fact this can be in part blamed not on
Yoko getting one over on muichiro but on
the swordsmiths getting in the way as
the swordsmiths run away muichiro has an
easier time deflecting needles with his
sword of course then Yoko says has the
poison begun paralyzing your arms and
legs so poison is another thing we see
in lower upper moons and the higher
stronger ones just don't need to rely on
it but it must be said it is useful in
cases like this in theory it will slow
down an opponent against which it could
be a close match of course Goku
contemplates how thrilling the
possibilities are if he can use a hashra
to create a new artwork his perfect
artwork would probably consist of all
hashra muichiro tells him to shut it and
he's boring him but when he goes to cut
yoko's neck Kyoko has another trick up
his sleeve it must be said yoko's Powers
have a lot of Versatility with this move
called blood demon art water prison pot
Yoko traps muichiro in a pot made of
water this of course should lead to
death by Suffocation muichiro tries to
cut his way out but he finds that the
water just expands with his sword gyoko
then makes a good point saying he
stopped muichiro's breathing which is a
demon slayer's greatest weapon so this
really does seem like a very overpowered
technique that is if it works like it
should all the while muichiro is
fighting Yoko we see that his fish
demons are still running amok they
attack swordsmiths showing how deadly
this demon can be even while fighting
and so far winning against the hashira
it's even commented that one of these
demons easily defeated the corps members
who protect this Village I hope everyone
understands that if a demon can create
demons that can easily even beat
combatants then that demon is very
strong indeed it takes hashira mitsuri
to finally take down these demons and
save the swordsmith so if mitsuri didn't
show up it's likely that Yoko even while
fighting with Shiro would have succeeded
in killing many so swordsmiths including
the most skilled Chief anyways back to
Drowning muichiro now hypotheticals may
always be inaccurate but one could at
least imagine that if gyoko paid close
attention or launched some more attacks
at muichiro while he was trapped he
might have won however he was
overconfident as we talked about before
and as was clear from the beginning of
his introduction he goes to do other
things and just leaves an undead
muichiro to himself Mutual thinks
himself that he has enough breath in his
lungs for one more attack but it's still
not enough and again the water moves
with his sword despite the fact that he
used a thrusting technique muichiro
starts to think he's done for while
gyoko continues attacking swordsmith and
in fact he gets distracted by Hagan
Azuka he sees him completely ignoring
him in Upper Moon with his astounding
level of concentration he's so absorbed
in his work that Yoko is jealous saying
he's never concentrated this hard as an
artist and it puts him to shame even
after attacking Him Yoko notices that
this man's hands never stop and his
concentration has an artist actually
saves haganazuka let me explain gyoko
thinks to himself that sure it would be
easy to kill him but he wants to find a
way to make him set aside that blade he
wants to break his concentration his ego
as an artist in this case messes him up
he could have quickly finished these
swordsmiths and maybe even return before
muichiro could have done anything but he
thinks he has time to mess around back
to muichiro and he thinks he is about to
die because he's run out of breath
kotetsu is the one who comes when
muichiro has given up and tries to help
cut him out in the process he gets
attacked and hurt by a small fish demon
the small fry stabs him in a vital spot
as muichiro notices muichiro wants him
to run and save himself but props to
kotetsu he keeps trying to help he blows
air bubbles to muichiro and these air
bubbles because breathing is the key to
the power of hashira let muichiro use an
attack to finally escape from the water
prison which is really cool when you
think about it even though kotetsu is
physically weak he was able to help
muchir to break out so it can be argued
that Yoko would have won if kotetsu
didn't bravely stay until he found a way
to help free the hashira so Props to
katetsu he's kind of like the real MVP
here so muichiro is now free but still
feeling the poison and his lungs heard
from all the water in them however
muichiro regains his memories at this
point and this coincides with a big
power-up he awakens a Demon Slayer Mark
and becomes stronger than ever before
this is also done in Epic fashion with
his dying twin from the flashback saying
the moo in muichiro is the moo in Mugen
meaning Infinity muichiro can tap into
an infinite strength as one of the
chosen in his flashback we even find out
muichiro is from a family of incredible
Swordsmen who use the very first form of
breathing techniques and yes later we
will figure out that muichiro is from
the same family of ancestors that
produce jorichi the strongest team is
there in history who embarrassed muzon
in a direct descendant of kokushibo
yorichi's twin brother who used Moon
breathing and became the strongest upper
Moon and before all this muichiro was
also singled out by Tangen as being
especially talented like yomei the
strongest hashira so in all fairness all
of this should be taken into account
when judging how strong Yoko is because
muichiro is not your average hashira
plus he's gotten stronger than he's ever
been before so don't let his young 14
year old age mislead you so this already
super talented Prodigy hashira awakens
the demon Sarah Mark power up which as I
explained with mitsuri in my how strong
is huntengu video it's pretty much like
going Super Saiyan for demon Slayers all
this time Yoko has been growing
increasingly frustrated that hakanazuka
just kept taking attacks and focusing on
his work even crushing one of his eyes
didn't stop hagarazuka this boss of
bosses didn't even cry out kyoku doesn't
want to kill him though since it will be
like admitting defeat admitting he can't
break his concentration and that he's
the worst artist but then muichiro comes
back and Yoko at this point notably is
still quick enough to dodge Yoko admits
his overconfidence when he says how I
have no idea I thought he was dying so I
wasn't paying any attention end quote
well against the hashra you probably
should have been paying attention is the
obvious thought right here so you can
tell that gyoko has a lot of flaws gyoko
then notices the mark and wonders how
despite the poison that muichiro attack
quicker than before even though gyoko
mostly dodged he did get cut a bit by
muichiro's previous attack he then
produces giant octopus tentacles that
wrap around muichiro however muichiro
succeeds in cutting up the tentacles to
gyoko's surprise he then moves in closer
to gyoko but Yoko transports saying
that's some fast chopping but he can't
match how quickly gyoko moves through
his pot however it's one of those epic
Delayed Reaction cuts and in fact yoko's
throat was caught a bit wujiro says so
cut it off all the way next time so
right now the stronger than ever despite
poisoning demon Sir Mark muichiro
appears to be winning muichiro actually
continues to also play mind games with
Yoko and with his banter clearly gets on
gyoko's nerves which arguably also
prevents Kyoko from focusing and giving
it his best when when he comments that
one of yoko's PODS shows shoddy
workmanship gyoko loses it looking more
upset than we've ever seen him the demon
is clearly not keeping his cool and
that's clearly not good for a fight
especially when you already lack caution
like Yoko gyoko then uses blood demon
art 10 000 gliding slime fish Kyoko
explains that 10 000 assassins will eat
muichiro down to his bones but muichiro
manages to avoid damage by cutting them
all however Kyoko continues to be tricky
and when cut these fish spray poison
absorbed through the skin yet muichiro
is so skilled right now that he manages
to spin and deflect all of it then as
muichiro is about to beat Him Yoko sheds
his skin and shows muichiro and us his
true form he says muichiro is only the
third to ever see this form and that
once he gets this serious no one has
ever survived gyoko Pro claims that in
this form these transparent scales are
stronger than Diamond he developed this
form inside his pot he tells muichiro to
kneel before this perfect beautiful form
but muichiro continues to get on gyoko's
nerves in this form Goku gets a
noticeable speed boost and what he
touches seems to sprout fish as well
gyoko says what do you think of my
god-like hands anyone my fists touch
turns into adorable fish so kind of like
the Midas touch just with fish instead
of gold he goes on to complement his own
speed his flexibility and toughness he
just keeps saying how great he is but
muichiro just mockingly grins which by
the way I love that grin and he says
even the strongest attacks are pointless
if they don't hit love this version of
muichiro toying with the upper Moon so
hilarious and it's also the more
rewarding because Yoko just keeps hyping
himself up he says behold my
magnificence when I get serious the two
are fighting at a high speed all the
time gyoko says stuff like how do you
like my moves that defy the laws of
nature thanks to my scales I have
complete freedom of movement it's
impossible to predict I love
contradicting laws of nature what kind
of food should I make you I'll rip off
that ugly head of your doors and replace
it with a beautiful fish head he thinks
he's already won against muichiro but he
can't get a finishing blow he attacks
muichiro but only slices his after image
he's shocked at how he keeps
disappearing Kyoko wonders what's going
on saying it's as if he's shrouded and
missed which I gotta say makes sense for
the missed breath style using Mist
hashira then muichiro drops such a
satisfying line as Goku is getting
frustrated he says did you think you
were the only one who wasn't being
serious before and then before Goku can
react muichiro cuts his neck that's
supposed to be tougher than diamonds it
takes a while for Goku to realize what
happened and is shocked when he realizes
muichiro has cut off his head we're then
told by the narrator how muchira was
able to win he used Miss breathing's
seventh form obscuring clouds this
technique uses wildly fluctuating speed
to confuse one's opponent when you show
yourself you move as slow as a turtle
but when you're hidden you move in the
blink of an eye its top speed is even
fat faster than gyoko who was upper Moon
5 already injured muichiro defiring
upper Moon and we're told this was
indeed an incredible turn of events
after this muichiro starts foaming from
the mouth and collapses since poison was
coursing through him so again the humans
are saved by working together the
swordsmiths helped turn muichiro so he
doesn't choke on the foam and will help
treat his wounds and poisoning however
what can't be denied is that demon Sir
Mark muichiro outclassed a final form
upper Moon 5 despite the poison running
through his veins so what can we
conclude from all this well upper Moon 5
gyoko definitely comes off as more bark
than bite but he wasn't all talk despite
his overconfidence we must keep in mind
that not only is muichiro considered one
of the two most gifted hashira and has
arguably the best genes out of all of
them he got way stronger over the course
of the fight when he regained his
memories and awakened the Super Saiyan
like Demon Slayer mark this as mentioned
allowed him to attain a speed faster
than Goku's so go couldn't land the hit
and muichiro could what's more he was
strong enough to cut through gyoko's
final four which was supposed to be
tougher than Diamond so I think it's
easy to underestimate yoko's full power
if you overlook how actually special and
strong Wichita is by the end of this
fight gyoko would have won if kotetsu
didn't come to muichiro's Aid with the
water prison but at the same time if
muichiro unlocked demon Sarah Mark
muichiro in the beginning that he would
have won before gyoko could even trap
him so what ifs are kind of pointless
since it's made clear full power
muichiro now surpasses full power gyoko
as mentioned in the huntegu video there
is a big jump from the lower three upper
moons and the top three upper moons and
that's clear here too Kyoko is stronger
than dakian gutaro so it's all the more
impressive that muichiro could solo him
at full power but gyoko is also weaker
than upper Moon 4. while upper Moon 4
its implied got stronger during his
fight even though he already started
high rank than Yoko Kyoko doesn't appear
to have gotten any stronger during the
course of this fight probably because he
was so overconfident and thought that
his final form was unbeatable so what's
the point of getting stronger he never
felt threatened until he died in the end
he was defeated before he knew what hit
him so not only is he not special among
upper moons his overconfidence and lack
of caution further hurts his chances of
winning any fight and although poising
sounds good in practice his poison
worked way too slow to affect the
outcome of his fight against muichiro so
it wasn't that useful the same can be
said for a lot of his Arsenal which
sounds good in practice but wasn't that
useful in actuality against a skilled
enough opponent however we are lucky
that mitsuri didn't face Kyoko since her
clumsiness compared to the more skilled
muichiro could have had dire
consequences against this demon who
could trap her in a water prison or turn
her into fish with one touch I don't
think she would have fared anywhere near
as well as muichiro did let me know in
the comments if you think she could have
pulled off the win too or no but that's
just the tip of the iceberg when it
comes to the insane demon moons and if
you want to know about all 18 demon
moons and Demon Slayer history including
hype ones only Ruby deal in rare bonus
materials then you don't want to miss my
all 18 demon moons explained and ranked
video link on screen right now and I'll
see you there